Michael I want to just jump right in and
start by asking about the inspiration
behind the underlying concepts and
theories in this film what are the
origins of these things the inspiration
for the film and themes that comes a
long way I worked on this movie for the
better part of eight years with my
co-writer and collaborator Ben neighbors
and I think you know we early on talked
about our own relationship with sound
both individuals who move to New York
City and you know weren't from there
originally and I think we we thought
about you know the way sound affected us
and played into our lives on a daily
basis a lot and I think I think whether
or not people realize it or not it's
this thing worse we all have a
relationship with sound and a lot of
times subconsciously and I think we were
both we're not scientists but we're
interested in science we're interested
in music and we wanted to explore those
things through this character and it
started through this idea for this house
turner character and we thought he was
this great kind of conduit to tell a
story about sound and yeah I just I said
I suppose our interest in the way sound
is playing into our lives this is based
on a short film so talk to us about the
journey that was an award jury
award-winning film in 2013 called pan
obsessed and it went on to do dozens of
other festivals what was that journey
like from short to feature well it's um
it's it's it's a long journey I first
first started working it was in 2011 I
was in California when I first read the
idea that Ben had sent me of kind of an
outline for a short story called
palimpsest and it had this character of
this house turner Anna and I really like
this character it sounded that I could
picture you know him wearing a tweed
blazer and carrying a satchel and I love
the idea of someone kind of walking
around with musical instrument equipment
but wasn't a musician and so that was
the germ of the idea and adapted that
into a screenplay and turned it into a
short film just for a short film I
really liked that medium but it was
never intended to be anything else and
we played it back in 2013 I played at
Sundance and I
we saw that there was you know it was
resonating with audiences there was a
conversation around it and it got kind
of been and I organically thinking about
what can we do we have a bigger story
here we like this character is there can
we kind of build more around his world
and we took a year it up you know
drafted out as a feature and I'd like to
say that we just jumped in and made the
movie but you know somehow six or seven
years pass and it takes a long time to
convince I suppose the the powers that
be the the financier is that it's it's
worthy to tell a movie about a somewhat
kind of you know I know didactic
scientist who lives in a basement and as
obsessed with sound so it's it was a
learning you know moment for me to
understand kind of you know what what
works on the page and how to convince
people but you know fortunately with
that time you got to develop and iron
things out more which I I never think is
a bad thing not it may be a sustainable
practice as a filmmaker and to make a
career but you know when all is said and
done it's it's it's part of making the
movie but a very long process and then
we finally found you know like-minded
people and sometime during that process
I was able to get the script a Peter
Sarsgaard who I had dreamed about being
in this role for quite a long time and
to my surprise when he when we finally
did get him the script and was attached
with a love letter that I wrote him it
was within a couple days that we were
sitting down and talking about the role
and I found at him you know this kind of
kindred spirit to the character that he
was playing someone as an actor and
human being just obsessed with sound and
considers himself to have a perfect
pitch or absolute pitch and you know
then suddenly once you start getting
stars attached everything kind of starts
moving along very quickly well in terms
of that score and the dovetailing of all
these elements because I mean we've got
score we've got sound design we also got
sound cues which I want to talk about
but the scores so dreamlike in spare and
it's yeah and he had very nuanced and
and occasionally very jolting and it for
me it references it kind of is an oral
reference to the concepts in the film
and also has a very specific way of
evoking New York
which I thought was really very striking
can you talk about how you achieved all
of that well we I guess in that very
very early conversation we had talked a
lot about early electronic music like
early 20th century composers and we
talked about jazz we talked about Peters
character and he has this very evolved
sense of music and and it's very
advanced and intellectual but at the
same time he's very precise and
methodical so I guess the the first
thing that I instinctually I just
started writing very kind of intricate
complex stuff and then ultimately taking
a sledgehammer to all of it and powering
it away to its most simple form is its
simplest state and that was one of the
joys of the collaboration I think was
really like getting to the heart of who
he is as a you know that there's
something about you know trying to
reference all of these sort of
specifically very highly evolved
intellectual musical ideas but also not
just like overwhelm you with that so to
be spared seemed to be quite important
but yeah we talked a lot about the
theremin and the instrument that's
really featured the most and the score
is actually a on des martinet which is a
1920s French electronic instrument
there's kind of like a very precise
theremin you it's like on a key bed and
you put your finger on it's on a wire
and you put your finger in a ring and
you can kind of play the it's very
precise and you play the velocity with
your left hand and with your right hand
you're kind of going up and down the
keyboard with this thing and it just
seemed to really work for him to have
that kind of it's very haunting but it's
also something kind of intricate and I
don't know it's like a plain song
sometimes as well what was the
experience of working with the cast like
that I mean you have performances from
Austin Pendleton Tony Romo Laurie or
rashida Jones Peter skarsgård I've been
I know you said that Peter was the first
one to the cast how did this all come
together and what was it like working
with these guys yeah I mean I guess I'm
lucky that it I was able to get such a
great cast you know
on my first feature I I suppose had a
lot of passion to get each one of them
specifically they were you know all
Causton Pendleton I'm glad you brought
him up he was someone who I've always
loved as a like a New York character
actor and can kind of do anything and he
had quitted coincidentally worked with
Peter he had directed Peter actually on
Broadway so they they kind of I love
that in real life they had this kind of
mentor you know relationship already and
it's you know Peter is a very generous
actor I found he's usually you know if
he has ideas it's usually to kind of
give his lines out or to cut back what
he's actually saying which I you know
really appreciate and is very modest and
and humbling to watch as an actor but
you know I think it's it's such a great
privilege to be able to you know work
with these things that you've had in
your head for so long and to finally
have it vocalized one of the first
things that Peter and I did when he came
on was we sat down in my apartment and
just recorded the entire script we had
an you know I read every single other
role and he read all of his but suddenly
it was um I realized I had this kind of
radio drama version of the movie after
that I can listen to and I just just
ended up using that as a tool and then
suddenly started out in music cues and
images on a timeline on my computer and
I I kind of felt like I could just watch
the movie and then all I had to do was
you know go out and shoot and fill in
those pieces but it was this great kind
of blueprint to have going in so I was
fortunate you know to work with actors
who were very generous with their time
and you know passionate about the work
and it was you know I say filmmaking is
often a pure form of collaboration and I
think that's certainly true with all of
the you know the cast that comes
together to do this and it's um you know
working with rashida Jones who is also
you know a filmmaker and writer in her
own right I think she's always best when
she was able to take scenes and you know
kind of meld it on the day and she's
very quick it you know being able to
kind of a depth
what kind of works best for her and so I
was really just I had a front-row seat
to be able to witness kind of these
things happening and and and in a great
way
thank you both very much I appreciate
your coming tonight